[Musique]
ceux qui veulent manifester le savent
le gouvernement mexicain se lève tôt dès
6 heures du matin ces enseignants
protestent contre leurs conditions de
travail devant le palais de la
présidence
car tous les matins c'est régulier comme
une messe le président andres manuel
lopez obrador se présente devant les
journalistes accrédités
ils appellent ça c'est magnin et l'asse
matinale celle-ci la 205e elles sont
retransmises en direct sur internet
youtube twitter à la radio en podcast
pendant environ une heure et année une
discipline qu'il imposait déjà lorsqu'il
était le maire très populaire de mexico
de 2000 à 2005
karam l'eau c'est comme ça qu'on le
surnomme n'est pas un président
ordinaire
il veut marquer profondément l'histoire
du mexique comme l'ont fait ses grands
prédécesseurs
benito juarez où la sao cardenas il veut
le transformer ça commence par de
l'austérité et il montre l'exemple
il a transformé la somptueuse résidence
présidentielle de los pinos pont musée
et il a mis en vente l'avion
présidentiel et une bonne partie de la
flotte gouvernementale parce qu'ils
voyagent en vols commerciaux
austérité pour l'état également faire
des économies et son aspect limitée et
tenait financière
les économies pour financer les
programmes sociaux pour les personnes
âgées d'abord il est jeune sans emploi
qui sont très nombreux et risque de
tomber dans la délinquance la plupart de
la population pense que pour la première
fois dans des décennies et le président
est préoccupé et par la situation de la
majorité la population qui est sous la
pauvreté et qui ne fonctionne pas
seulement pour les élites
et ça marche son taux de popularité
reste très élevé dans les classes
populaires de cette petite ville par
exemple
san mateo atteint au capital du soulier
tout le monde ici vent ou fabrique des
chaussures
oui on appuie lopez obrador il y a des
résultats on sent qu'il fait quelque
chose
il travaille bien
lópez obrador a promis qu'il
n'augmenterait pas les impôts pour que
notamment en même temps d'une pause tous
ses états financiers dont elle de sa
rolls comme l' austérité et nos permis
tient dans la corde jean sony n'ait été
très les mater une telle idée qui est si
le gouvernement n'était pas co robes
corolles l'argent qui on pouvait
utiliser tes succès il faut dire que je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de la shac qui
peut être appliquée de façon différente
s'il n'ya pas corruption je suis
d'accord mais pas assez
pas assez parce que l'économie mexicaine
ne va pas bien
la croissance est à zéro et les
relations entre le président et les
investisseurs les hommes d'affaires ne
sont pas très claires alors qu'il a plus
que jamais besoin d'eux les signaux sont
contradictoires
l'annulation du nouvel aéroport de
mexico les viaducs inachevé du train
rapide mexico toluca a laissé à
l'abandon alors qu'il est construit à
80%
tout cela laisse un goût plutôt amer et
son père faire si vous voudrez sommes
les plus clairement au milieu ils vont
faire les profs ou des désastres
il ya des mécontents amelot n'a pas
augmenté les impôts mais il en exige
davantage le paiement dans la classe
moyenne
cette commerçante de san mateo se plaint
de payer trop d'impôts sous prétexte
d'être propriétaire de sa boutique
c'est bien beau de donner de l'argent
aux pauvres dit elle mais ça ne sort pas
de la pauvreté qui les sort de la
pauvreté c'est de leur donner des
emplois c'est le ski takrit meyrannes
simple s6 et les résultats économiques
commencent à être un défi à sa
popularité à son approbation personnel
il est pragmatique il pourrait faire des
changements amelot est un vieux routier
de la politique qui a juré de place et
l'ont été au dessus de tout une vertu
que les mexicains ont très rarement
reconnues chez leurs dirigeants mais qui
ne suffira probablement pas pour
transformer tout un pays